have a special question and answer
program on the the backdrop to all this
right now the uk heat wave we'll do our
best to answer as many of your questions
as we can before 8 00 pm but uh let me
introduce you first of all to our panel
of guests to answer those questions that
you've been sending in all day we've got
dr frederick otto a senior lecturer in
climate science at the grantham
institute for climate change and former
associate director of oxford
university's environmental change
institute also professor dame helen
stoke lampard chair of the academy of
medical royal colleges and a practicing
gp in litchfield joanna robinson sky
news meteorologist and tom heath
presenter of sky news's weekly climate
show welcome to you all and thank you
very much indeed for
agreeing to ask our audiences questions
about what is going on what will
continue to go on at the moment so uh
let's kick off with our first question
uh this one for you joanna from boye
who asks quite simply
why do heat waves happen um tell us
about the meteorological background
of course
well we need areas of high pressure high
pressure brings us settled conditions
and with those settled conditions we can
get see the temperatures rising day on
day in the summer with the sun you know
at its strongest we can see day on day
temperature rises with high pressure we
have the azores high it can move in
across western parts of europe and
affect the uk
now if that high pressure system
stays across the uk for long enough we
can see those day-to-day risers like i
just said the air is sinking down from
into the high pressure system that's
rising the temperatures further but to
see the extreme heats like we've seen
today and yesterday we need to tap into
some very hot air so that's when we need
a southerly wind the high pressure needs
to be in the exact right position to
draw in the heat from africa and across
other parts of western europe into the
uk that's when we see those extreme heat
conditions so heat waves they do occur
naturally but we are seeing you know as
um global temperatures rise due to human
activity we are seeing in increasing
more frequent heat waves longer and more
intense heat waves like we've seen today
so the met office do have a way of
they have a definition for a heat wave
and that uses certain thresholds across
different areas of the country so you
need to have at least three days to be a
heat wave and
temperatures in say london area need to
reach 28 degrees or more and then other
parts of the country say scotland need
to be 25 degrees or more but yes high
pressure is what we need and sometimes
we get a blocking pattern so high up in
the atmosphere we can get this blocking
pattern so the high pressure system
doesn't move and then we get this kind
of heat dome so the heat just builds so
that's how we get heat waves okay joanna
thanks so that's the uh why um and this
then about the future uh dr
otto i wonder if you could deal with
this for us uh from melissa are we to
expect more wildfires in the uk due to
the heat like we are seeing in europe
yes it's the very short answer to that
question because um fire weather
conditions are basically made up of um
three components so one is
high temperatures
third one is um
low humidity or or just dry conditions
and
and then the third one is is wind and
even if well the wind
uh situation is not changing very much
with climate change and
uh because of the temperatures are every
time there is a heat wave now
temperatures are hotter than they would
have been without climate change and
also we see many more heat waves so we
will just see many more of these fire
weather conditions in the uk and we have
already seen an increase in in the last
years in wildfires spreading around the
uk so this is definitely
one of the consequences of this very
strong increase in heat waves that we
see
okay that's pretty clear this one for
you doctor
sorry professor stokes lampard angie
asks why do people keep dying in
waterways i mean it is such a sad
feature it always happens in in hot
weather is it simply that they can't
swim is the water too cold is it the
currents
is there a medical explanation cold
water is one reason isn't it
it's a combination of factors cold water
is certainly one of them and cold water
shock people jumping into water
expecting it to be tepid and then
discovering it's bitterly cold still for
lots of reasons about the way that water
is slow to warmer
but also a lot of people who die are
often young and enthusiastic and rather
adventurous and they're leaping into
waters that they don't know what's down
below so they're not swimming in places
they're used to swimming in not many
people get into trouble in a swimming
pool or in a uh sea situation where
there are lifeguards around this is
people in unsupervised waterways taking
a chance because it looks so inviting
um there are often and in those sort of
waterways there are often obstacles just
under the water so people jump in and
literally injure themselves because of
you know
obstacles under the water um currents
are certainly a problem so in rivers and
streams and in estuaries currents can
really take even the stronger swimmer by
surprise so there are a whole myriad of
things but basically
the human condition is such that water
looks so tempting to us when we're
desperately hot but please never jump
into water get into water that you don't
know what's there that isn't safe and
isn't tested never ever go swimming
alone uh in these situations um and try
and find other ways to cool off and stay
safe
that's uh very sound advice um
another feature of what we've been
seeing tom you take this one on and it
is the travel disruption it seems too
hot too cold um
you know we never seem to get it just
right we've been hearing from network
rail today about the uh amounts of rail
travel that's had to be
curtailed uh rex asks i've traveled all
over the world to far hotter countries
than the uk and their buses trains and
planes all run fine and their roads
don't melt why are we so awful at
dealing with weather extremes what do
you think
well the clue there is kind of in the
question he goes to far hotter countries
so those countries will be dealing with
heat far more often far more of the time
we are blessed or if you like cursed in
the uk with weather that can vary a lot
not only throughout the year but between
different years
and the slightly harsh fact is that
resilience costs money
so if you're going to make your railway
tracks resilient to 40 degrees
centigrade plus
that's going to cost some money and how
often are you going to
get those temperatures now we may take
the decision that we're going to see
more of them so that is an investment
and we have seen the same thing albeit
not recently in uh in not that long ago
decades or so past five years past and
we've had very heavy snowfalls and
people ask why haven't we got the
gritters why haven't we got the
snowplows or heathrow de-icers i there's
not that long ago i remember that and um
you know the truth is once again that
costs money so it is a slight balance
between what we are prepared to pay for
resilience which you might not need for
five ten maybe more years so if you want
to be able to be sure that everybody can
travel all the time uh on our public
transport or even on our private
transport on the road network you know
it's an investment to do that and that
is a that is a political and economic in
the end it's a public decision about
where we think our priorities should lie
i see and if you don't then uh when it
comes to the extremes then be prepared
for the disruption
thanks tom um tell asks this one uh
helen stokes lampard again
i think this one's for you what can be
done for asthmatics
in this heat at work especially if they
have no air conditioning we we do know a
lot of people have real difficulties is
it is it the pressure the dry air or
what
so asthma is one of the whole range of
lung conditions and almost all of them
are adversely impacted in extremely hot
weather they're also impacted when
pollution levels are higher and this is
a classic one where all many nearly
every aspect of climate change is bad
for the planet is bad for our health so
it is in all our interest to be
addressing the climate change challenge
but specifically this question about
people with respiratory difficulties in
the workplace and you really need to be
speaking to your line manager and
occupational health if you have
respiratory problems and exceptional
weather is coming and asking for every
dispensation possible to work in a
cooler environment obviously all
employers have a responsibility to do
their best to keep workplaces as cool
and as safe as possible to ensure that
you are safe and protected you know that
is your responsibility as an employer
and certainly making sure you have your
inhalers with you if you are affected by
hay fever make sure that you are up to
date with your antihistamines and you're
taking them and i mean these are simple
straightforward things but doing
everything that you can to help yourself
making sure that you're using cool
clothes and flannels to wipe yourself
down and lots of cold drinks will help
but at the end of the day if your health
is being impacted by the heated work
speak to your manager and get out to
there and get to a cooler place you do
not want to risk an asthma attack or a
worsening of your breathing conditions
it's not you know it's a frightening
it's dangerous and we've been speaking
earlier about the most vulnerable uh in
society actually if you've got a chronic
lung condition you are vulnerable right
now you need to take it seriously please
yeah and uh just following on from that
then we hear though the pressures then
that is putting on the emergency
services when it comes to hospitals just
this increase in 999 calls when as we
know the health service is already under
such intense pressure
yes that's right i mean i have to say
the amazingly good warnings that we've
had from our meteorological colleagues
over the past fortnight have meant that
the nhs like the other emergency
services have stepped up and pulled out
all the stops yet again to build up the
resources so that when the extra calls
and demands came that we were ready for
it and most hospitals and most gp
surgeries have actually coped very well
there are some exceptions often where
systems have fallen down or people have
been off sick themselves
but generally the public have been as
responsible as they can be and the
health service has
really amazingly done it yet again we're
not through it yet we've got another
probably 24 hours 36 hours until the
impacts um are easy because obviously
there's a lag after the weather know the
temperatures start to fall before the
health effects um are the risks of
passing
but
this is going to become a more recurrent
pattern and this is something about
protecting our whole system we need more
resilience in our nhs and emergency
services
this isn't a one-off i think we would be
very naive if we think well we survived
the great heatwave of 2022 this is a
recurrent problem we need to plan and
prepare for it we need an nhs that can
be working throughout this system i mean
we have myriad problems with storage of
medications obviously the heat on our
patients the heat on our staff but our
i.t and infrastructure is struggling
there are many stories of scanners and
testing equipment falling over and
computers shutting up shop because
they're a bit aged
and also our buildings in the nhs you
know our estate was not built for this
sort of weather i personally work in a
gp surgery built in the 1980s most of
the building has no air conditioning
it's terribly insulated so it's like a
complete oven in there and the number of
patients who i saw yesterday who were
lamenting how hideous it was being in
the surgery and i i did feel for them i
didn't gently like to point out that of
all of us had been working in it all day
uh but yeah it's not great there's a
long way to go yeah got a question for
you joanna thanks for that talent a
question for you joanna following on
from some of the practical advice that
uh dame helen was giving there and uh
gavin wants some more practical advice
poor gavin lives in a top four flat
can't open his windows because one of
his cats tries to climb out except for
fans and cold showers how can i keep
myself and my flat cool he asks is there
any more advice you can offer joanna
oh it's so hard to try and keep yourself
cool especially when at night time
temperatures you know last night didn't
fall below 25 degrees in some places it
is very tricky the advice is actually in
the daytime to actually have your
windows closed your curtains drawn and
your blinds down you don't want to be
bringing in that hot air from outside
into your house so the advice is to
actually have your windows
and doors closed during the daytime and
then to open them in the evening to let
that cooler air in
but you can't open the windows and so it
is hard but if you have a fan there is
advice to perhaps have a bowl of cold
water with ice in it and to put it in
front of the fan and that can act a bit
like an air conditioning unit it will um
bring cooler conditions across the room
that you're in with the fan and the ice
cold water
other ways to cool yourself down there's
things like cool water on your wrists
and having your feet in cool water i
mean obviously it's important to keep
hydrated as well so and drinking plenty
of water as well so
those are some of the ways that you can
try and keep cool but it is quite tricky
when the temperatures are so high julie
noted um stay with us we're going to
take a short break now thank you very
much indeed you're watching a sky news
question and answer special on the
heatwave as i say more questions coming
up next uh including advice for autistic
children in this unprecedented heatwave
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good evening well you don't need telling
it's never been this hot in the uk and
tonight a major incident has been
declared in london fires are burning on
the outskirts of london after the heat
caused grass fires which then spread to
some homes and businesses from
wennington in greater london laura
bundock reports on a village that has
found itself on the front line of the
climate crisis
thick black smoke rose up from the
village and below the fire ripped
through buildings
flames so fierce and so high nothing
could stop them spreading with dangerous
and terrifying speed
it started in wellington green
caught fire and compost heap the wind's
not helped found flames it's
gone right across the village taking out
the uh everyone on the green staying at
the church and slowly weaving its way
along the main roads
fanned by wind but fuelled by brittle
dry ground
this fire was impossible to stop so it's
been really scary and i was even tearing
i was crying my little one was crying as
well blessing was at home with her
two-month-old baby when the police told
her to leave i don't even know what to
say because i've never seen i used to
see this kind of fires on tv i never
thought in my in my wildest dream that
would happen to us i've been so scared
but thank god we've seen some passerbys
who've been giving us water and stuff
the whole village was evacuated leaving
residents stranded and shocked my
partner has got copd
he can't breathe he's not allowed at the
house
and he's panicking so the police officer
just got hold of him and and we had to
go at the house and he shut the door
after us firefighters are used to
extreme temperatures but the ferocity of
this fire was something else we've
probably never seen um weather-related
incidents particularly to do with heat
on this scale before
but we do have well-rehearsed and
practiced plans in place to be able to
make sure that we're prioritizing our
resources as winds changed direction
they fought to contain and control the
flames people on the ground doing all
they could to help
we were warned the heat wave would bring
danger but no one expected something
like this
laura bundock sky news
well as you know with these record
temperatures in mind we're doing our
very best to answer your questions about
the uk heat wave let me reintroduce the
panel of experts i've got with me this
evening dr frederic otto is a senior
lecturer in climate science at the
grantham institute for climate change
professor dame hellisto lampard chair of
the academy of medical royal colleges
and practicing gp in litchfield joanna
robinson
our very own meteorologist and tom heat
presenter of sky news's weekly climate
show well uh welcome once again let's
crack on with these questions so many
different aspects of what's going on to
address from our own audience been
sending questions in all day um alex
asks that and it uh relates to us in the
media i suppose um asks is the media
slightly exaggerating all this seems
like a normal summer to me does it alex
some
what do you think dr otto normal summer
uh
no it's not a normal summer temperatures
of 40 degrees in london would have been
basically impossible only a few decades
ago
and even now it's still a rare event
but because we have
uh
burned fossil fuels for the last
centuries and have increasingly fast
done this the last few decades
these temperatures are now possible
there would have been a heatwave without
climate change but it would not be as
hard as this one and also we're not just
seeing a heat wave in the uk right now
we are seeing heat waves across western
europe the us
north africa we've seen heat waves in
china we've seen heat days in south asia
earlier this year and it's not just this
year it was the same last year and the
year before so heat waves have become
much hotter more frequent than they
would have otherwise been so this is
what
will be a normal summer if we don't stop
burning fossil fuels but at the moment
this is still
an extreme event but one that is
possible now it would not have been
otherwise and even if we did
just to follow about how long it's all
going to take dr otto even if we did
stop burning fossil fuels entirely right
now which of course is not going to
happen
because of the centuries you've
described it all building up presumably
it's going to take for several decades
the very fastest for it to go down again
it won't go down so if we would stop
burning fossil fuels now
then we would but then global
temperatures would basically stop at the
level they are at now at which is about
1.2 degrees and that would mean that the
likelihood for a heat wave like this
will continue to be the likelihood it is
right now which uh i haven't calculated
the numbers
yet but um
but other aspects of course uh like sea
level rise and glacier meld and other
slow reacting parts of the climate
system will continue to change even when
we've stopped burning fossil fuels okay
and following on from that then tom this
one from vinsible
um it will it be possible to adapt how
we insulate our homes then as these heat
waves are
here to stay adapt how we insulate our
homes i suppose that cuts both ways
doesn't it i mean it uh works for us in
the winters as well
it does indeed a home that is well
insulated is well insulated from both
heat and cold so largely that is a good
idea whichever your extreme you're
facing there are other things you can do
to combat the heat things like put
canopies over windows a bit like you see
on on the front of shots that can
actually have a very very big effect on
the amount of heat that comes through
the windows in your house so is that
something that might be worth
investigating um the the thing i am i
must say i'm personally very cautious
about is the idea of installing a lot of
air conditioners
because to me that's a bit like buying a
fridge and hiding in it while your house
is burning down around
it's a very very temporary solution and
kind of worse than that actually
the energy used to run the air
conditioners which is nearly all fossil
fuel
is worse than the climate change problem
in fact globally more energy is used in
cooling than heating
and whilst i uh absolutely uh
agree with everything uh
dame helen was saying about that the
health risks of this i think we have to
be a little bit careful about those of
us who are experiencing discomfort or a
bit of sweating reaching for the
checkbook and buying a uh
and buying an air conditioner that was a
bit of a dated reference but uh
reaching for the card and buying uh
buying an air conditioner i think that's
something to be
you know something to be very careful
about clearly if there are health
reasons why that's required then that's
important but for the rest of us these
more passive
methods that i talked about at the start
i think are the way to go and basically
endure a bit of sweating
indeed nothing wrong with that it's
entirely natural and it's a very
interesting point you made there tom i
had no idea that more energy is consumed
globally on air conditioning than it is
on heating
yeah and the
difference is getting wider as
as the planet heats up and slightly as
more people kind of come to expect
perfect temperatures
um which is something we didn't expect
uh 50 years ago so we heat more and we
cool more because we're after this kind
of goldilocks not too hot not too cold
zone in the middle well sometimes we
might have to endure as i say a little
bit of discomfort yeah okay uh
interesting thanks for that tom a
question to you professor dame helen
stokes lampard from jason um well yeah
i've no idea what the answer is going to
be interested to hear what you say what
advice can you give parents of autistic
children who are struggling to help
their children cope it's very difficult
isn't it when circumstances
change so radically
yes um children or indeed anyone who has
autistic disorders uh really struggle
with change and of course when you've
got a massive change in the weather like
this this is a change just like taking
them to a new place is a change
so the same principles apply about a
weather event as do any other event that
you plan with them which is plan
talk about in advance what's coming and
we are blessed nowadays that we get
fantastic forecasts we knew this was
coming we've known for several weeks
this was coming um and
so talk about what's happening and what
they're likely to experience and what's
going to be different
depending on the severity and the age of
the child you may want to plan some
strategies for what works to cool them
down so some of them hate certain
textures and so you may not find that
the simple giving them a nice lolly or
washing them down with a cool flannel as
you would perhaps another child will
work as well and you may
need to think possibly a misting spray
of water will be something they can
engage with and getting them used to it
practicing with it in readiness it's
probably the biggest single thing and
obviously taking time to explain it in a
way that they can best understand
for those who are very severely affected
and who where the communication
difficulties are profound
then you work in sort of in that is the
case of just trying to just cooling
blankets and you have to take over a bit
more then and understand that the
behavioral challenges are going to be
difficult and it's
it's very very hard you know your child
or your loved one best and so planning
has got to be the single biggest thing
in the same way for extreme cold weather
and i take tom's point very much about
absolutely we should be learning to live
with some extremes and a bit of sweating
for those of us who are fit and well is
absolutely fine as is a bit of shivering
and getting another jumper on but for
those who can't understand what's going
on and this applies to all sorts of
cognitive impairment people with
dementia another classic example and
very young children we do have to be
planning for all this practicing for all
this and being prepared for all this
and ultimately we do definitely need to
improve our buildings estate both
obviously for the nhs but for all of us
in our domestic situation our work
environments too okay we're talking
about planning got a question for you
joe from abby
just we talked about i suppose the
future further out the years to come and
what needs to be done but abby just
wants to ask about i suppose the next
few months will there be further heat
waves this year she asks what do the
charts tell you we know over the next
week or so it's going to get a little
bit cooler but i suppose a few years
back we regard what's coming up as as a
heat wave 27 28 degrees
exactly that i mentioned earlier the
definition for a heat wave by the met
office it's you know three days reaching
28 degrees in the southeast and 25
degrees further north different you know
different thresholds for different
counties across the uk so yes what we've
seen today is extreme heat that you know
it's not the heat wave definition that
we've you know i've just talked about so
yes it's certainly possible that we
could see a heat wave occurring again
later in the summer you know we're still
only in the middle part of july so
there's still time for another heat wave
you just mentioned that temperatures are
likely to dip and as we go through the
next few days but there are signs that
temperatures will um increase again um
early next week not to the level that
we've seen today i'm not talking
anything like that but potentially you
know we just need three days of
temperatures of 28 degrees or more and
you know then that would be defined as a
heat wave so it is possible we have
already had a heat wave this summer you
know
not to this extent like i've just talked
about but yes we've already had a heat
wave before it is possible again through
the summer and you know china we talked
about other places across the globe that
have been having heatwave china's had
three heat waves already this summer so
it's certainly possible and something
that we will keep an eye on but i'm not
expecting anything to the levels that
we've seen today it really has been a
historic day with records broken fingers
crossed break coming our way you're
watching sky news uh you're watching a
special question and answer session on
the heat wave uh we'll be answering more
of your questions
including the thought a lot of people
have this will a hot summer lead to a
cold winter
is coming your way next
[Music]
climate change is with us and it's
becoming critical but the fight back is
on
coal is under fire whereas wind power is
booming
you can now have burgers made out of
these rather than those and no need for
fuel just rely on the vital spark
i'm tom heap and i'm joining sky news
for special weekend editions of the
climate show where we'll meet the people
hit by the crisis and also those
delivering crafty solutions
in the end the question is can we reach
a world that isn't based on
burning stuff
find out on the climate show on sky news
it blows your mind as you said
that we can look back
and we're going further back we're going
back to 13 and a half billion years ago
and you think of that
this light has been traveling at the
speed of light
186 000 miles per second
for 13 and a half billion years
so we're capturing the light
from the formation of the first galaxy
after the beginning we're learning a lot
more about the universe certainly how
large it is
ultimately who are we
what are we
how did we get here what are the things
are there others out there
this telescope is so precise
that we're going to be able to analyze
the chemicals on other planets
revolving around other suns
and determine if it's a habitable
atmosphere hubble is mainly the optical
what you see with your eye
this is able to look back
through all of the space cosmic dust
because we are capturing
infrared light
infrared light is a much longer light
wave and it is not held up
by the cosmic dust
and so
that's how we're seeing further it was
an extraordinary experience
when you look out your
not seeing much more than what you're
seeing from
the face of the earth
however what is astounding
is looking back at the earth
as you
orbit the earth every 90 minutes
i flew
as a member of congress
as a politician i was struck by what i
saw
because i didn't see racial division
i didn't see
political division
i didn't see religious division
i saw that we're all in this together
as citizens of planet earth
welcome back now most of the uk has been
sweltering on the hottest day ever
recorded over 34 locations in total
exceeded the uk's previous temperature
record of 38.7 degrees celsius the
country's hottest ever temperature 40.3
degrees c recorded in konigsbee in
lincolnshire scotland recorded its
hottest day on record the temperature
reached 34.8 degrees celsius in the
scottish borders according to
provisional met office figures well
skies katharina vittotsi reports on a
day of record temperatures
after the uk's warmest night came its
hottest ever day
previous heat records were smashed
temperatures peaked at 40.2 degrees
celsius at london heathrow and here in
the town of conningsby in lincolnshire
it is absolutely sweltering here
conningsby is seeing temperatures well
over 40 degrees celsius this afternoon
and now alongside london heathrow having
that title of not only being the hottest
location in the uk today but being the
hottest british place on record
for people working it's been
overwhelming
the kitchen has been quite unbearable
my business partner robbie's in the
kitchen at the moment and he's not
loving life at all i think it's probably
hitting about 50 degrees in there at the
moment as the sun beat down unrelenting
some schools stayed shut
transport was disrupted
we've already paid for tickets which are
we'll have to clean back and i've just
done online 231 pounds to glasgow and
we're told that's not running from here
either it really surprises me because
i'm from germany and um
we don't
that would never happen the uk
government needs to step up and
start preparing us for climate change
and getting serious about delivering net
zero
police urge people again to avoid diving
into rivers and canals and reservoirs as
the search continued for a 14 year old
boy believed to have drowned in the
river thames in west london
across the country everyone and
everything did what they could to keep
cool
more northerly cities better used to
colder weather have adapted
in york gritters that normally deal with
icy roads were out spreading one of
those has been telling people to stay
inside if they can and the impact of
that is city centres that today have
looked a little bit like this far
quieter than you'd normally expect for a
sunny day with businesses that simply
decided to stay shut
this gin distillery had to stop
production entirely the first time due
to heat
it is a bit of a blow for all the
traders here everyone must be suffering
today it normally is teeming here and
you can as you can probably see it's
pretty quiet um we'd normally have
queues possibly forming outside the shop
not today
today was a day not to enjoy the sun but
to survive it tomorrow's cooler forecast
will bring relief in more ways than one
catherine of totsi sky news
well let's get back to our panel of
experts who have been answering your
questions about the heatwave we've only
got a few minutes left so dr otto i'd
like to put this one to you um from ben
is this extreme heat a result of global
warming or is it just an improbable
occurrence that is not likely to happen
again anytime soon
it is um well every weather event
whether extreme or not is is always a
combination of several causes so there
is never um that that that there's just
one single cause so we do have here a
role to play of just the natural chaotic
variability of the weather system so we
have a high pressure system
we have hot air coming in from from
africa but
without climate change this heat wave
would not be as hot as it is we would
not have broken the heat records in the
way uh that we have seen today without
climate change so climate change did
play a big role in this heat wave okay
one more and it's uh this one yeah well
is it true uh does a hot summer lead to
a cold winter
tom discuss or maybe my grandma and your
grandma may have may be better at that
hot summer
joanne i mean
my personal view is i hope so and i'm a
little bit uh i'm a little bit of an
outlier on that i actually get more
upset about warm when warm weather in
the winter than i do in the summer
because i kind of like the seasonality
of our climate and also i i happen to
like snow and ice that might make me
weird but it's true and uh
it's really there also you can see some
worrying changes in the overall uh the
overall climate pattern i suspect there
is no actual truth in if you'll forgive
the old-fashioned slur the old wives
tale that uh a hot uh summer is followed
by a cold winter but
okay and uh five seconds on that joanna
no
not necessarily a link just people
perhaps hope for one yeah i think that's
come from in the past but yeah no
there's no link uh there's no
statistical proof to show that there
will be a cold winter now that's yeah
that's not true okay well plenty of
statistical proof from you all dr
frederick also thank you very much
indeed professor dame helen stoke
lampard joanna robinson and tom heap
thank you all for cracking on through
all those many many questions many more
questions then remaining coming up at
the top of the hour about just how hot
it got how hot it's going to stay and uh
in also including the fires that have
broken out the wildfires that have
broken out around the uk including this
particular one to the east of london
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's eight o'clock this is sky news
tonight with me dermottman and wildfires
break out around london as the uk
records its highest ever temperature
hundreds of firefighters battle the
flames in extreme heat as a major
incident is declared across london
homes and businesses are destroyed as
fields and grasslands turn into a lethal
tinder box
ambulance trusts see a rise in 999 calls
as the heat wave leads to an increase in
demand
and a warning to be cautious in open
water after several drownings